towards the end of the 20th century a
celebrated romanian french philosopher
was invited to speak in zurich he was
introduced with rhetorical pomp and
flattering comparisons to the likes of
keyguard and Schopenhauer
the speaker smiled and immediately
confounded his German interpreter by
beginning his presentation with the
words may Ernest recount the goner but
I'm just a joker a few of his critics
might agree but they would be very wrong
for Emil Cioran
is very much worthy of inclusion in the
line of the greatest French and European
moral philosophers and writers but Maxim
stretching back to Montaigne Shafa
Pascal and LaRouche Foucault cheerin was
born in rasinari Romania in April 1911
his father was a Greek Orthodox priest
both facts were to be key in his later
works
the writers Romanian origins are often
taken as the source of a brooding
romantic fatalistic temperament while
his father's ecclesiastical calling
finds echoes in his son's unswerving
preoccupation with themes of religion
sainthood and the dangers and joys of
atheism in 1934 at the age of only 23 he
published his first book in Romanian on
the heights of despair the book contains
in embryo much of the lucidly bleak
nihilistic thinking that georan
developed throughout his life he
explained that writing had been an
alternative to shooting himself this is
an author to read at moments of despair
and melancholy he doesn't depress us
merely makes us feel less alone with our
many sorrows here is a peek inside his
work it isn't worth the bother of
killing yourself since you always kill
yourself too late
only optimists commit suicide optimists
who no longer succeed at being optimists
the others having no reason to live why
would they have any to die write books
only if you're going to say in them the
things you would never dare confide to
anyone
and what do you do from morning to night
I endure myself 1937 proved a pivotal
year for cheerin he moved to Paris and
soon became a French citizen he never
returned to the country of his birth it
was a move that provided him with one
more reason to be melancholic exile and
yet Gio ran asserted that anyone who
doesn't feel themselves to be in exile
has no imagination only the village
idiot thinks they belong he noted
cheerin sat out the Second World War in
Paris in its aftermath he approached the
famous publishing house galley ma with
his first work in French a short history
of decay published in 1949 writing in
French was he said like writing a love
letter with a dictionary the book became
a best-seller but first in a series of
devastatingly wicked and dark texts
composed mainly of aphorisms and tart
short essays each of cheer and titles
comes as a provocation or a punch
syllogisms of bitterness the temptation
to exist and his masterpiece the trouble
with being born each book deals
relentlessly with themes of illness
death and suicide it was a rather
touching irony that the author lived to
the ripe old age of 84 by the time
Charan died in 1995 he had become a cult
in France attracting the sort of faddish
attention he witheringly denounced in
his work every life he maintained is
utterly peculiar and wholly unimportant
in the age of Walt Disney this kind of
darkness matters children's writings
belong in the line of this great aloof
European Miserables lists including the
harsh four core leopardi Nietzsche and
Samuel Beckett like them
he saw civilization as an absurd
distraction from the ultimate
meaninglessness of existence only an
idiot could think there is any point to
any of this he insisted but Sheeran
always kept his wit and good cheer one
of his greatest sources of sorrow was
that he couldn't sleep very well and was
often up at 3 a.m. he walk around the
streets of Paris until dawn he noted
sardonically in the trouble
being born what is that one crucifixion
compared to the daily kind any insomniac
suffers Chiron was obsessed by suicide
but better to live he wrote and yet
think and act as though one were already
dead after all he said why deprive
oneself of the consoling idea of no
longer being around continuing to live
is possible only because of the
deficiencies of our imagination and our
memories
he wrote I am simply an accident why
take any of this so seriously
but suicide was a constant relief as an
idea we dread the future only when we
are not sure we can kill ourselves when
we want to having always lived in fear
of being surprised by the worst I have
tried in every circumstance to get a
head start flinging myself into
misfortune long before it could occur
our age is notably optimistic and it
makes us suffer hugely from being so we
are all in private a lot sadder than we
are allowed to admit writers like Gian
provide an occasion for the sadness
inside all of us to be communally
expressed and thereby a little but only
a little
diminished and softened in his beautiful
book the trouble with being born cheerin
wrote I can be friends with people only
when they are at their lowest point and
have neither the desire nor the strength
to restore the habitual sentimental
illusions it's precisely in that kind of
mood I moved into which all thoughtful
people must probably sink on a fairly
regular basis that we are blessed to
find the dark and consoling works of
Emile Charan waiting for us we love
bringing you these films if you want to
help us to keep bringing you thoughtful
content please consider supporting us by
visiting our shop at the link on your
screen now
you